is that the right word
it's not like a pain in the ass to get
anywhere yeah
it takes like an hour to get to a mic in
LA from North Hollywood
yeah
[Music]
here everything's on 6th Street you
barely have to move you better let your
drive
there's like
how many clubs there
we're here on Cinema
four five six
yeah that's great hate hate La it's like
everyone's there because
uh they have like they they monopolize
success they took it out of every town
and put it in LA and now it's like we
don't need them anymore yeah like The
Comedy Store model was kind of
like Universal oh outdated I mean that's
the model that they're using at the
mothership not outdated but like
I don't know what I mean I mean I mean
it's like perfect for that specific
scenario I feel like it's going back to
what it should be like once all those
big people left now they're like giving
it back to the
door guys and the people like they're
like developing more yeah it's more like
for people it's for like the younger
Talent now you're not just like the
superstars to
play around in yeah for sure I know is
that better I think so I have a few
friends that work there now that are
getting great stage time and opening up
the main room for five minutes and nice
[__] like that yeah I mean I think it's
better that everyone left because it was
like
it was toxic just to have everyone there
and everyone competing for the same
spots it's like this should be in
multiple cities and there wasn't that
many spots like it was it was all like
shitty bar shows and backyard stuff yeah
they weren't that's the same with New
York too all the best Crowds Are at
professional shows
if you want to go to a comedy show you
don't go to like a local [__] show
you're like oh I want to see comedy
let's go five more minutes on the subway
to find an actual show yeah from a
professional club like I was you know
you know Dante Chang do you remember yes
I was hosting one of his mics for a
while and right before I left I got up
with the Laugh Factory a couple times on
a couple of shows but other than that
like you couldn't just get those spots
you had to like know someone yeah and
then it's just because about knowing
people and then your comedy is just like
an ancillary part of your comedy the
real focus is like knowing people and
climbing the ladder and being seen and
also we're able to like you we're paying
for mics too that was a big there's a
big No-No disadvantage well I think it
makes sense just because if you go to a
bar and there's like 20 people just you
know I yeah yucking it up
ruining the atmosphere with their shitty
comedy you're driving away customers
yeah so then you should pay something
but I think a lot of that money went to
the host yeah I like how
like because they paid to be there like
they paid attention so it was kind of
constructive But like after a while you
were just like
hanging with your friends and doing
doing mics with the same people you're
just paying for the air conditioning
yeah the roof like I don't feel like I
was getting better you could do that
same mic here yeah or anywhere but the
mics here
I mean like in a house yeah it just
would feel weird something about the
venue like oh you're going to a
professional place now you can't act
crazy but if you're in a house it's like
yeah there's it doesn't feel as good as
the bar yeah like a lot of these Brewery
shows here like it's just too loud and
there's too much going on in the
background for it to be at a good comedy
show you know yeah but I think like the
number of shitty shows in Austin is far
fewer than a lot of other cities
I don't I haven't been I've been to
Denver there's a few good shows there
but I haven't been to New York yet
um I mean it's just uh it's just that
people in Austin are excited about
comedy the audience is here are amazing
well they're coming here for it it's
like insane yeah and they're like
learning how to take jokes they're not
just like you know reacting based on
keywords they're like listening and yeah
figuring out who you are and they're so
charitable yeah they'll take the best
light like one of my favorite things is
seeing someone like Brian Holtzman go up
here like not
for like people that haven't seen him
yeah and just seeing how they react to
that guy and it's always like
Hit or Miss but like they don't know
what they're seeing and it's like
I don't know I like that here yeah
yeah cause they're so it's like an uh
European Coming to America and coughing
on everyone with smallpox yeah they have
no immune system for shitty comedy yeah
for just good because then you build up
a crustiness to real comedy we have a
lot of that here too though what shitty
comedy yeah not a lot but there's some
there's there's a lot yeah more coming
in every day I know it's chances are if
you're successful and funny in your city
you're not going to want to move to a
completely new city and start over yeah
so the people that move are usually not
that good yeah there's a lot of it's
like every every week There's new people
here yeah can you uh plug in that cord
that's going into the thing this one
yeah uh not to the to the camera
there we go and can you move it a little
bit to my right
a little more
and then plug it back in again
okay
that should be good
yeah I think uh in the beginning of
Austin A lot of people are coming in
because it was everything else was
closed so I think some people moved here
and they were good that's why I think
that's why I came here yeah but like it
was I came three times and it was like
picking up each time yeah it was like
this at first I didn't want to come here
but then by the second time I visited I
was like this is where we should be yeah
this is so much better than LA right now
I mean if you're gonna like do the
non-pandemic thing you should just
[__] do it you shouldn't just have
like oh we're doing a mic on the
sidewalk and everyone has to wear a mask
it's like [__] it we're gonna get it
there's a couple sidewalk mics here that
there were there are right now I think
there's one yeah it's like this one like
midnight but it's like there's no point
in half-assing it that's what I think is
like during the pandemic I was like oh
if you guys aren't gonna do this [__]
then why am I gonna suffer through it
yeah there's no point in one person
quarantining when everyone else isn't
yeah for sure like no that's how it was
in L.A like and no one knew what to do
like some people wanted to go out and do
comedy and other people yeah I mean it
takes discipline to be like I'm not
gonna go out and go to Red Lobster every
night and you know consume things to
make myself feel better for not creating
anything
uh and then if you're tired of doing
that it's staying in if you can't do
that because you're you know mentally
weak then you're just gonna go out and
uh a lot of people I think in America
don't know how to just be alone and sit
still because they're always like
constantly moving and going crazy and
they had to go out it's like
that was awesome I had a great time like
getting free money and just sitting
around yeah I was richer than I ever was
more money and I just [__] like is
this all it took buying good groceries
and two thousand dollars a month yeah it
was amazing that's all I did and then it
ran out and I was like I got an
unemployment too I got like pretty good
unemployment yeah I got the extra 600
and I got I got all of it for like
months I know I could have done more but
I was like there's no way it's that easy
to just get money and turns out it was
and I just missed out on two months of
free money yeah I should have did
something with some of that money like I
just blew it all and well that's part of
it I think you have to go through that
to get to using money responsibly yeah
like there's a few people I know here
that were like I invested some and I won
on the stock but if you're panicky and
poverty stricken then you gotta like
just go ah and then once you settle down
you're like okay I have the tiger and
the Lamborghini now what do I want to do
yeah like I saved some of it but I
didn't like do anything with it I liked
it well you probably should get more
money yeah it's probably not enough that
you got it's not I I had enough to come
here
and like survive for a few months so it
got me that that's all you need yeah
it's amazing how little we need I know
it's nice here it's way more cheap yeah
and you can live like a human you don't
have to like stuff yourself in a tiny
closet and it was all about working you
know get a backyard and you get to air
your balls out and shave your pubes
outside go sit in the river like a lazy
piece of [__]
you're not supposed to do that you don't
want to sit in the river the river's
like toxic yeah I don't go I was just I
just figured that's what people do yeah
I would never do that you mean in la no
here here yeah it doesn't the [__]
River's all damned up they have this
beautiful River and they just [__]
the best part of a river is it flows
and if it doesn't flow it doesn't keep
itself clean
and you just have this giant Dam it's
like we have enough electricity we don't
need to Dam up Rivers it kills a
wildlife have you seen the documentary
damnation no it's on Netflix I saw it
and now I'm anti-damn but I don't know
how much we actually need dams people
seem to like dams everything's too crazy
there's too many documentaries it's all
everything like I saw there's I saw a
story about or it was like a movie
about a McDonald's worker or no guy he
would call like fast food places and
tell them like one of their employees
would steal was stealing and he would
somehow coerce the manager into like
strip searching their employee I saw
that documentary and then I never heard
of the story ever and then like two days
later after I watched the documentary
it's like there's a Netflix movie on it
it's like why have I never heard of all
this crazy [__] that happens yeah I
don't know some people don't like
hearing about that [__] so they keep it
down they're like oh we're that easily
manipulatable
manipulatable yeah manipul manipulatable
manipulatable manipulable the nipples
are we recording yeah nice I hope so
um yeah I think uh is a really
disturbing story because you know this
manager wanted to do this to the his
poor little employee and just like have
his hands all over her well it was crazy
how how dumb these people were which
person
the manager the manager well how is he
though he's doing it on purpose but the
but the guy on the phone was saying he
was a cop and he was like you have to
strip search your it was like a like a
17 year old female employee like they
were like I don't want to do it and they
like somehow
yeah I mean I know like with the
structure of Corporations and like
hierarchy you're like oh well he's my
boss he can do whatever he wants that's
pretty much what it was and yeah it's
gross yeah no there should be no
hierarchy or we should severely limit
hierarchy and or just don't work every
day like don't work at McDonald's that
would be
a start
um I uh I think people are just bursting
sexually they want to like [__] touch
each other and if there's a dude on the
phone that's telling you to do that then
it's like oh okay
awesome nobody's [__] everyone in
Austin's [__] not compared to Brazil
I mean we're [__] in the south of
America puritanical country in the most
puritanical part of it where do you
think [__] the most
probably like Africa or South America
it's gonna say Africa probably I mean
they have that dick you're going to want
to use it the big who do you think is
[__] the least probably like
I'd say I would say like people in Ohio
yeah somewhere like poor but not too
poor because if you're too poor then
you're gonna start [__] because
you're bored poor people [__] a lot yeah
but if you're like too rich then
I think that could also [__] up your
sexuality yeah you start liking weird
[__] yeah you start like going after
like animals and kids that you get bored
of [__] yeah you're like pussy's no
good anymore take something from someone
yeah
I need to ruin someone's life
take it off
where did you see that documentary
it was on Netflix or something maybe
Netflix it was a long time ago right no
it was a couple months ago oh [__] I saw
it a long time that was a long time ago
I think the documentary was old that I
never saw but the movie that they made
about it was recent the movie was just
weird though because like they had to
like have like this girl like naked in
this office like reenacting the whole
[__] I think I saw it on Dateline or
something and then like his wife would
come in and see this naked girl and then
she would be like oh I just needed an
envelope and then walk out yeah and they
were suing her too like you should have
known something was happening well he
would Target like small towns so like
people are kind of Dumber there right
yeah but if you see her husband with a
naked woman
and you just go oh that's normal I bet
she was getting off on it like oh yeah
just kind of touched my husband's not
touching her I hope this guy calls back
does it for me
yeah I think
I think that girl was dumb too
yeah I would have left she should have
been like no I quit McDonald's yeah call
the cops
but you know
it's kind of [__] up if you're it's
like a sunk cost fallacy it's like oh
well he made me take off my shoes I
might as well take off my shirt oh what
a sunk what sunk cost fallacy what was
that it's like if he's if you have
already paid for something then you can
get them to pay a hundred dollars more
because they already
paid for it
okay so it's like oh I already lost
money on this I need to get that money
back so let me keep spending money on it
and maybe something good will happen at
the end that'll make it all worth it it
wasn't that how people get rich
investing yeah losing and
betting more I don't know how things
work I'm kind of stupid
um yeah I guess people do get money from
some cost fallacy but it can also make
you poor because then you spend all your
money yeah I've been spending money on I
went to Vegas and after going to Vegas
for like four days it made me like
spend money frivolously when I got back
nothing but I guess is a state of mind
yeah it's I could see how you could ruin
your you could do anything there you
could ruin your life in a weekend it's
[__] crazy you could shoot a tank
they have tanks that is it's insane you
can shoot from inside a tank out or you
can shoot at a tank
in in the tank oh no it's like a
military like shooting range there yeah
that's fun I love that that exists there
should be a place where you can do
anything it's just sad because there's
so many homeless people there I know I
just found that out that they're like
living under the street I saw an
Instagram video there's like tunnels of
people I didn't know that I don't I
don't know how common that is but I know
that they exist I don't know if it's the
majority of people I think majority of
people just live above ground but true
during the summer I bet you have to live
underground time to go down below
but then they have to get food people
are like why don't you just be homeless
in the suburbs why you meet like 10
people a [__] day there Vegas is
weird because like it's just the the
city and then it's just flat like
suburbs for a bit and then it just stops
and then there's nothing yeah it's like
why did you choose to stop here yeah my
girlfriend was like I want to move here
I was like we're not moving to Vegas
like that would be
terrible yeah but it's like at some
point you have to be like okay we don't
have enough money for that part
we're just gonna draw a line around this
part yeah let's go to the poor part of
Vegas
I meant like the outskirts oh like the
part where it turns into desert
that'd be cool just go start your own
town if you had like a backyard that was
an entire desert that's how Salt Lake
City is too I've never been there it's
like pink
the the lake and then people just stop
they're like okay this is the end of the
town
it's kind of depressing
yeah it's like there's no more people
over there this is the end of our
programming they [__] a lot there I
think
some of them do
no Mormons yeah super religious people
no they have a tight control in
sexuality but don't they have like tons
of wives yeah well how often can one guy
[__] multiple women true
I mean okay bad take time snow [__]
in Utah
no Utah [__]
that was a hot take
so um
what do you do to write jokes
I just try to take stuff from my life
yeah and turn it into something make it
into a joke because I have a lot of
stupid [__] that I've done or been
through and I try I try not to write
like one-liners that like don't mean
anything you know what I mean like I
wanna I try to write stuff that I can
keep for a while and still use it's like
still relevant so you don't want to just
come up with a joke about like how
you know Ovaltine or like how dog food
tastes weird or yeah that's not really
you're not like writing jokes just to
write jokes like a Tonight Show right
yeah that's not really my style you want
to have jokes that have an emotional
punch where some guy like [__] you
over and you're like this is why you're
an idiot and you want to take it out
revenge on stage yeah like right now I'm
trying to write one about how
um
well first of all
apparently I I carry gum on me and
I'm trying to write a joke now about how
it's like uh
so the past couple nights like a couple
friends have asked for gum and I'm like
I have gum but it's like loose and
they're like what do you mean and I have
like a bag and I have like a pouch in
the bag that has like loose gum because
I buy the big bag yeah and
um
apparently it's like weird that I have
loose gum and offered to people
and so is it an individual rappers no
it's just pieces of gum it's in a little
bag yeah I keep like a little pouch of
the individual pieces what's the pouch
made of it's like a little plastic like
container like a cup yeah like a little
like a Tic Tac sort of case oh so you
have you bought your own gum container
well I got the big bag and then you dump
it into your little a little bit and
people think that's weird they're like I
don't want that you're loose gum
yeah I just try to write [__] about my
weird [__] organic
pasture-raised gum
that's crazy I mean it takes an extra
level of
[__] to do it and people are so used
to like corporatized hygienic like
sterilized I didn't touch the gum I just
dumped it into this I know would you
take my loose gum yeah see I have faith
I drink tap water yeah I eat food off
the ground sometimes if it fell just
recently yeah people are like really
sterilize and like they they they're
very corporatized like they don't want
anything with a human touch on it
because that's dirty all your sushi is
touched
Sushi whenever you go out and get sushi
they're not they don't have gloves on
they touch every piece of fish you know
yeah but we all eat if you're eating
sushi from someone who wears gloves
that's bad Sushi that's why people sushi
how do you write jokes
I uh think of something that annoys me
or like something stupid that a TSA
agent did or like a flight attendant I
think flight attendants are the worst
they're always trying to
check your bags for no reason
and never gotten caught with anything
at the airport
no not really they let you bring in
pretty much anything nowadays yeah it's
true you could fly with weed and
mushrooms mushrooms and acid maybe pens
yeah it's just they just
they're they have like an attitude
sometimes and like I don't know I don't
I don't like Americans with power they
just try to take as much as they can
yeah you make 13 an hour yeah this is
this is how they get make up for it yeah
you were not by yelling at people part
of Homeland Security yeah kind of I get
to tell you what you are but chances are
you're not gonna catch anything
because people are flying every day
and no nothing ever happens did you get
covered yeah like three or four times
yeah I had it twice I was like in
it was after I got vaccinated too I got
vaccinated just so I can like perform it
someplace yeah
I ended up getting it anyway
but don't you think it was less severe
because you got vaccinated yeah for sure
the second time I got it I didn't feel
anything yeah it was just like normal
for I just said it was just like
uh
bureaucratic like oh technically I have
covet yeah it was just like in me I
didn't have a fever or anything I think
as long as you got past the first three
four months then it kind of died down it
kind of became less strong yeah and now
I don't even know what's going on people
are still getting it and it's weird it's
like I have covered it's like all right
come on out it's okay you can come to
the comedy club yeah and I have
gonorrhea so what
just don't kiss me
um Mario about to get a foggy after the
pool oh what this is The Joe Rogan
podcast Circa 2004 people say
it's a chat going oh there's people
watching us live yeah it's live are they
say that anything but no you didn't you
didn't even tell me we started recording
well that's how everyone does that oh
you just started talking yeah haven't
you seen Pete Holmes or Mark Maron or
Joe Rogan
yeah like I just kind of start in the
middle
yeah a thought did anybody say anything
bad about me
um people said something good about you
wouldn't you like rather focus on that
true did anybody say anything good about
me yet probably oh you don't read them
you just let them no
I mean that's what Joe Rogan did Circa
2004 because he didn't read the the chat
I heard he still doesn't read the
comments yeah he said he doesn't read
anything which is smart do you
do you try not to do you go on the kill
Tony Reddit no not on the Reddit the
Reddit is hates me yeah the place is
they hit everyone yeah they hate
everyone if they just go there but uh I
read uh the Instagram comments those are
usually fine yeah those are positive but
I know what I hate about myself I think
it's I think you just gotta
keep yourself honest and I think the
internet just wants to keep you honest
all the time but you can't just be
keeping yourself honest you also have to
like take Flights of Fancy and be
creative and make creative leaps and
just being like Oh I have a big tooth or
whatever yeah it isn't going to help you
do that so I think it's a good part to
have I don't think you should not have
the part that's critical of yourself but
I don't think that should be a hundred
percent of your self-talk yeah I think
that's a very small part small but
important and the internet just wants to
be that for you especially the American
internet yeah I really hate America we
want you to kill yourself
yeah I think America is just a crazy
country I think we're just like survival
is uh is a privilege so if there's
someone that's like doing great and
you're just barely surviving you're like
why does this guy get to have great
things and I'm barely surviving [__]
this guy yeah he doesn't deserve it
human rights because human rights is
like uh cries that you get in America
it's not something that you have like in
Scandinavia you're like oh I'm
Scandinavian I'm I'm a part of the
community but here it's just like we
don't need you yeah so do something
quick you have to earn it you piece of
[__] yeah which I think is good because
you know it makes you feel badass but I
think mostly it's bad yeah because even
if you're successful in it you have this
toxic mentality of like I conquered
other people yeah like I don't want to
beat my friends I just want yeah and all
successful people eventually have to
have a fuel source that isn't toxic that
isn't about destroying humans
but uh yeah I mean I I don't read the
comments now all right so you shouldn't
none of none of you should read them on
the show I mean none of the regulars
should read the comments because I think
that people are suffering and that's
what I take from it it's like oh it's
just like a people are sad they don't I
don't think they realize that there's
like
they're like actual people that they're
talking about yeah they just think it's
theoretical I mean characters we do
comedy all the time yeah we talk to
people all the time these people they
might talk to two people all day yeah
and they're people that they already
know they're just like and they're
having nothing conversations they're not
trying to say the craziest [__] to each
other yeah they're just in Idaho and
they're pissed that they're not in
Austin I'm gonna leave a comment like
yeah
hopefully they'll enjoy the beautiful
Scenic scenes in Idaho it must be
perfect there right now if it's like a
hundred and whatever here
it's actually probably nice and peaceful
in Idaho but they don't have [__] to do
there yeah I was out in the woods or in
the desert camping and it's fun and it's
great it's great for you as a human but
you know we have brains and prefrontal
cortexes that need
something more than just oh I'm
surviving yeah like you need to connect
with the internet and like Beyonce and
all that [__] that we know is out there
once you know it's out there to choose
not to go into it is kind of
hard to do but unless you're crazy yeah
you have to be crazy to go live in the
woods yeah forever yeah but didn't you
live on the in their van like out yeah
for like six months at Mac out in the
wilderness yeah probably like two months
or three months or something it wasn't a
long time I mean I did I was like a
tourist but
I uh it was fun it looked like fun thank
you you knew me from back then right
yeah you stuck in La for a minute uh
yeah is that where we met briefly you
were I saw you like a backyard open mic
is that the Mexican guy that had his
Mexican family there
that was a cool show a lot of people
came out yeah he built that thing out
for a couple months like during the
pandemic like that was one of like the
cool spots to go like it was actually
upon this Mexican backyard his dad would
sell hot chocolate for a dollar I know
and they were so Mexican or like so dad
like like he barely spoke English and it
was just positive energy yeah there was
a Pupusa lady right on the corner like
[__] best food you can get up there
but it was in the suburbs there was
nothing but houses for miles it was like
North
of like north north of North Hollywood
like just keeps getting more Mexican he
lived up in like Sylmar or something and
yeah I think that was similar and then
you have to go past do you have to go
past the pass to get there yeah but you
you weren't there for too long were you
no I left in like November or December
can I get that water
where'd you go after that after oh I
went to Superstition Mountain Joshua
Tree camped out there for a while then I
went to Yuma stayed with my friend
uh uh and then from Yuma I went to like
New Mexico went to Carlsbad Cavern and
mount Superstition or uh Mount Guadalupe
mountain did you do comedy along the way
no I did comedy in Tucson for a little
bit with my friend who I did math with
nice you did math yeah I tried it yeah
smoked it yeah it's a little craft pipe
how was that it was good it was like you
could feel the energy but it wasn't like
a good source of energy I didn't feel
like it was a healthy source of energy
but I had energy
you only did it once
yeah all right smoke meth once like I
want to smoke meth once yeah everyone
should smoke meth once but like I've
done heroin a bunch so like
which is better a bunch of heroin or
meth once probably a bunch of heroin
I'd probably take like if you had an
oxycontin right I mean I'd probably do
it not heroin but
yeah you're not afraid of being addicted
because I feel like that's more
addictive
no I've I've taken a couple Percocets
here and there over the but it's been
forever it's not really on my do you
think you have like a personality type
that is good with painkillers and
opiates because you're very chill and it
makes you more chill
not yeah it's it's a bad combo because
it just makes me Chiller
but it's I've it's been forever so it's
like not even like on my I'm not like
counting I'm like oh I'm 14 years clean
from heroin like I'm not like counting
yeah you're not like one of those
weirdos yeah I'm 25 years sober it's
like what that's so unnecessary just
like do it yeah why are you still
counting I know it's like this idea of
like uh Puritan
culture it's like you got to be right
with the Lord or whatever yeah it's like
you're either doing it or you're not
you're sitting or you're not you're
heaven or hell it's just very black and
white which I don't think is healthy
because that's why a lot of people have
schizophrenia I had to go to outpatient
rehab for like four months
because I got caught it's heroin
eventually
eventually you get caught but yeah I
could never get into like the higher
power thing like it didn't make sense to
me yeah it's like they were like you
have to have a higher power
I'm not that desperate yeah this didn't
make sense when I was I'm just bored in
church so it thought yeah well my higher
power is the audience or the crowd or
Humanity see that makes sense now but I
didn't have have that I didn't know how
that was an option the audience my
higher power yeah is this Open Mic
audience in Silmar power in the lab is
the pupusa lady outside yeah that guy's
house James was his name yeah James Rios
yeah he was so nice he still is he came
here a couple times he's still oh really
I've never even talked to him that many
times in L.A every time he sees me still
he's so [__] nice
that's what I think all these [__]
people in Austin that I [__] can't
stand if I saw them 10 years down the
road on in a airport I'd be like oh hey
yeah a lot of them say hi but I know
they're Faking It
yeah but I don't know Austin seems kind
of weird now
clicky yeah everyone wants to like get
by with not being as funny they want to
get by with friendships
friendships and personality yeah
but hey
do what you gotta do because you're in
to Comedy for friendship you're gonna
quit comedy soon because it's not the
best place to make friends there's
plenty of plenty of other places to
that's only when I was like getting down
on the [__] I was like I wish I want to
be part of it more but they were like
[__] that you're not here to have fun
you're here to I mean you're here to
have fun but like this is like you're
here to get better not yeah I'm here to
like uh get better as an artist and like
learn and grow I'm not here to like yeah
kiss ass and learn how to riff like a
[__] like I can white person they out
drinking lone Stars till 2am every night
yeah unless that's who you are like
Keith Ray I'm sure that he's having a
great time
doing all that love Keith
I know open mics are perfect for guys
who are like drunk and you know that
love that bar life because you're around
bars all the time unfortunately most
people who do comedy look like us
they're like nerds yeah
they're like what am I doing at a bar I
don't know how to interact with people
yeah just on my phone and [__]
getting around and I think there'd be a
lot more extroverted people if like
people were Chiller I think there's a
lot of negative energy so then people
are like more shut down yeah there's a
lot of
fakeness here but I try to stay out of
it what do you mean by fakeness just the
people just like hey how are you you got
any shows I could be on yeah stuff like
that but I don't want to talk too much
[__] you know well I feel like I'm
I'm like mean enough to where people
that are like that don't want to talk to
me yeah
I mean I have my people that I talk [__]
too yeah you have your friend grew up
here you have your own Clique yeah the
click that hates the other click I guess
I do yeah the click that hates clicks
true what click is that who's your click
beside your girlfriend
obviously who do I like
who do you like
that's a good question I don't really
like too many people I mean I like the
people I work I like the most of the
Vulcan dudes they're all good people
yeah come on first you work at Vulcan or
I work at Sunset yeah part-time I like
bunford
[Music]
um
yeah I mean I think there's a lot of
great people it's just
it's hard for me to get along with some
certain people because I'm in a very
specific part of my life where I need
certain things from people that I don't
think they're ready to give me yeah what
do you mean
um like maybe like just
people that are chill and not like you
know too anxious or desperate or
that are like listeners not people that
are just big personalities that just try
to take over a whole conversation yeah I
try to not be too desperate yeah you're
definitely very chill almost too chill I
know it's a problem yeah I'd be like
this on stage and I'm like I need to
like I'm fine you guys are freaking out
yeah I need to perk the [__] up
sometimes but I don't know if that's the
answer
not perked up but like
maybe a little more energy or a little
more a tad more 10 more that's what you
feel I mean that maybe that's part of
your thing is start like swinging my
arms like you're you're constant uh uh
disdain your your need to have a little
more energy all the time is probably
like oh this guy
you know has that thing where he thinks
he needs more energy maybe that that
works for you because if you think you
need more energy maybe it makes you more
self-conscious or insecure or something
true that I'm riddled with that
comedy just like makes me insecure if
you're quiet and you're confident then
people don't like that but if you're
quiet and insecure they're like oh this
guy just hates himself but if you're
quiet and confident they're like oh this
guy just hates me
yeah I'm not too confident I should be a
little more confident I'm working on it
why why what why be more confident why I
mean I think the drives and striving to
be more confident is probably good for
you because then it keeps you moving it
keeps you from stagnating and being like
an arrogant poet or writer but I don't
think it's I think I think like this
idea of like who we think we should be
is like ridiculous like we should be
like a agent I mean there's nothing I
can do about it like I'm I'm just me
like your personality type is probably
not great for a capitalistic Society of
money hungry you know parasitic people
but I think it's a CEO material no you
don't want to be CEO material they don't
make anything they just take what other
people make and then just repackage it
true
I'm learning a lot about myself today
is therapy no it's just I'm like telling
I'm talking to myself really I'm just
trying to convince myself that I don't
need a change so I don't have to work on
myself and I can just stagnate and
lay around but yeah I mean I find it
hard to make friends
um in the scene yeah like there's
certain people that I'm like comfortable
talking to and then there's other people
that like
I don't know how to have a conversation
with them yeah like care people are just
too focused on success and yeah
like I don't want to talk about that too
much yeah I'd rather be doing it talking
about as shows and having fun [__] like
that it's like yeah like I talk about
comedy for five minutes and even if they
do talk about like writing jokes and
stuff it's like how do I get it better
I'm so worried about it it's like yeah I
know I can be like that too but
um I think uh
I think it's a good scene I uh
I think there is
there's a lot that could be improved
about it like what like a little more
rigor a little more like hey you gotta
actually write jokes instead of just
relying on
you know like being cute and quirky to
get an audience to like you yeah I think
a lot of people love how they look and
who they are here which I hate because I
hate myself I think their personality is
gonna sell it yeah I think it's a
southern thing yeah you still need to
have jokes yeah be funny it's just like
look how cute I am it's like
I'm not here to [__] anybody yeah I'll
go to a strip club
like why are you dressed like that for
this bar show and
I'm not just I'm mostly talking about
dudes too which is so [__] weird when
dudes are into their face
they take selfies and like usually dudes
with beards
yeah like I mean I'll take like a joke
selfie but I'm never like taking like a
serious picture of myself like oh look
at me at the lane now I'm like sticking
my tongue out with the [__] stupid
filter something about a dude doing that
when a girl does that it's like oh yeah
of course we all want to see this but
when a dude does it it's like there's no
demand for this the only person that
wants this is you yeah less dude selfies
yeah you should never take a picture of
yourself as a dude you should always be
pointing out words and then posting it
of yourself that's insane yeah
yeah and you shouldn't love your face
that much if you love your face that
much that's a tactical disadvantage you
have to be like doing something like
cool like like when you'll post a
picture yourself like flying a drone
it's like that's fine but like you just
can't just like post a picture of
yourself for no reason like we don't
yeah we don't need that no one wants to
see a man a man's uses in physical or
visual it's you know like things getting
done mechanical like I don't even think
dude should be out with their shirts off
in public I think that's disgusting you
should be doing it out of Shame yeah
like nobody it's not fair because women
can't do it because they'll get harassed
but like I do I don't want you to see
your pecs like put your [__] chest
away you know but I think it's just
utilitarian you can tell who's doing it
for what reason like a homeless guy
being shirtless that's yeah you can tell
that he needs that but like the way that
guys look when they're shirtless
oh you're having to be looking at me
that's crazy you were looking at my
chest like yeah it's like don't do that
there's no end to that there's no good
ending you're gonna be a male model no
one respects male models they're like
okay you look good now can you change
tires
yeah everyone hates us everyone loves
what we do no one loves who we are yeah
you white straight piece of [__] like
I'm the minority here I'm straight in
Austin and it's weird exactly what are
you hanging out what do you mean why are
you around so many gay you know like I
just assume everyone here is bisexual
liberals that are [__] each other all
that stuff that's the vibe I got that
everyone in Austin is by I think it's
scary to be in Austin because like you
never know if someone's gonna shoot you
for talking to a girl it's like that's
my woman
you've seen that
uh have I seen it have you seen anybody
pull a gun out here no I haven't seen
anyone pull a gun out here besides
online or something
but yeah I mean it's just like a very
machismo culture and it's not like
California where it's like free love man
I can talk to whoever I want it's like
that's my woman yeah get away from her
boy yeah
foreign
you want to read the chat sure what's it
say
it says find God
will do hell though
way less and bombs and chats than the
Jerry U streams days I mean people
saying it just to clarify
well that's pretty much it I saw my name
what did it say about me Mario about to
get something
goes up a little bit I don't think it
matters but
you can find it
I saw someone say can we get something
more interesting
this is a podcast [__]
you want to watch Red Bull motorcycle
jumps go watch that I'm sorry that we're
not
cool enough have you ever changed the
tire on a car yes I've changed the tire
on a car I can change a tire
I know how to change a tire
I know how to change myself yeah
which is better than a tire
um yeah I've changed the tire I was in
uh the U District in Seattle and I ran
over a piece of glass in the parking lot
and I had to change the tire to go home
you can change it right there I changed
it right there nice So the instructions
are right there it's man [__] dude
you're a man congratulations you have to
know how to undo a bolt sometimes
they're rusted on though then you gotta
call the [__] picture
yeah
one time I got a flat tire and I had
just got
surgery for a hernia so I couldn't
loosen it up yeah so I had to call the
people but that was the only time I
couldn't change a tire I think being
able to do things physically is nice but
it's not really necessary we should be
able to in a perfect world just be
handicapped and just float around
that's why when I'm in crosswalks I
don't feel bad because I'm like I'm
allowed to be handicapped you're lucky
that I'm able-bodied I'm not gonna run
I'm just gonna walk nice you're one of
those I'm gonna take my time I mean cars
shouldn't exist on most roads anyways it
should be walkable communities dude I
hate the drivers here they're insane it
makes the fight that's why I can't have
a gun I would point it at someone
driving like my road rage is out of
control here I mean people here will see
that you're changing lanes and then try
to pass you
yeah or they'll just cut you off for no
reason and then you beep and they flick
you off and it's like what is uh that
just starts I got cut off three times on
the way here and I was like [__] 10
minutes away like it never ends yeah I
mean people will take an advantage if
they can they will try to beat you yeah
it's a game and it's like you're not
supposed to be playing it and they're
winning in this game that no one else is
playing but them and then if I see it it
makes me mad like I just don't know how
to drive in Texas like I have to be more
aggressive so I think yeah they want you
to go right up to the bumper yeah I'm
gonna start like driving like an [__]
if you leave any room someone's gonna
take that spot in front of you like I'll
be going 90 on the highway in the left
lane and like my girl will be like you
need to go faster I'm like there's cars
behind you I'm like I'm going 90 90 in
there I know people here don't drive a
certain speed or they're not trying to
get there at a certain time they're just
trying to drive faster than you yeah it
doesn't so it doesn't matter how fast
you drive and it's just you gotta want
it and the people the other people
behind you in the 90s it's like this is
there's no they're they're on your app
like I don't care it doesn't make any
sense this isn't a good way to transport
people to get everyone in cars racing
each other I was getting mad at each
other that's right 90 miles per hour and
right ass like we know what route I-35
everyone gets on I-35 make that a
[__] train
we know that people go up and down that
[__] so [__] make it a train and
everyone can squeeze onto a [__]
train and we you do the same route over
and over again less friction you don't
have to pay for like tire pressure and
you know the wheels and the engine and
the [__] axle it's like get a train
everyone's going this way this is the
busiest Highway everyone gets on it to
do anything don't they have one they
have a light rail that goes like
sideways and up and
you know it's not a consistent schedule
and no one rides it everyone just needs
a self-driving Tesla and then we can a
train put it on a track
okay we'll give you your train why do
you need a Tesla that's like an
inefficient train because they're fun
have you driven one yeah I've driven a
Tesla of course you have that was a dumb
question I did it when I was broke I
haven't driven a Tesla since
I became a kill Tony regular
humble brag
how is being irregular is it still fun
it's great I mean I'm doing this
competition thing which can be stressful
but I like it because it shuts people up
it's like you think you could do better
you know people have tried yeah
all the golden ticket winners
I mean I'm sure someone can do better
but I'm doing my you know I've done 180
minutes
yeah I'm doing my 181st best set and
you're doing your third best set how
much
of those 180 minutes to have you kept
that you like you probably like 40
50. 30.
it's not even
there's a lot of stuff that's good but
you know most of it is a lot of it's
topical sometimes too so it's topical
but yeah I mean
sometimes I'm like well this is all I
got for this week so I don't want to do
that stuff
and some of it I work on some of it I've
fall in and out of lava with you know
it's just like any other bits yeah
but yeah I mean I could definitely go
back into my kill Tony archive and
figure out what I could say you still
have them all you keep everything I have
a list of all the jokes that I've said
and I have like a gap
like right right around the time right
before I went to the Mothership there
was like a three month Gap where I
wasn't writing it down but it's online I
can always look at it which is nice
yeah I keep pretty good track of most of
my stuff that I write
it's all written in notes I don't have
it in spreadsheets like you but it's a
notes yeah like in on the phone
yeah I have it all in Notes too it's so
much more convenient because you can
read it all over
and you don't have to like shuffle
through things you can just Google 2023
or 2017. yeah I used to do the notebook
but then I kind of stopped writing in
that because it's harder to edit and
yeah it's annoying yeah you can't just
control F [__] yeah
the good thing is that you can
um
you can always have it with you you
don't need a battery or whatever but
it's on the cloud for me so
who are you uh going up against next
nobody for now I have a reprieve until
my next bad set nice
yeah I mean
I'm just a dude that became a regular
I'm not saying I'm super human I'm not
saying I'm the funniest person in the
world
I'm uh
I like joke writing I like performing
for audiences I like telling people what
I think I like you know
getting up in front of an audience and
saying stupid [__] in front of them yeah
um but yeah I mean I don't want to be
like
a clown I don't think
I got into comedy from that angle I'm
more like a writer
a nerd that yeah I started writing jokes
I try to be
what's the word
picky with the writing like I don't want
to read anything about writing yeah I'm
gay about it I for sure over obsessed
about it you're a size queen about jokes
yeah
I think it's good to be picky
I think
like I'm I'm aware of what's
like we all know it's like happy and not
good yeah and I try to stay away from
that as much as I can and some people
don't they yeah but that's my strategy
don't be a hack that's my what I'm
trying to do that's good you know
everyone has a different definition of
hack
um I think uh I mean everything's been
done before
but I think it's good to um
I think it's good to do things that you
know like oh everyone
has talked about having a child but you
know it's interesting to hear different
people's perspective on having a child
yeah I think I think Roseanne gave great
advice on Phil Tony and she said just
talk about yourself that's all you can
do and
that's all I'm trying to do but isn't
is it like airplane food being weird a
part of yourself
if you can make it funny I guess but
that's hack you're willing to do that no
I wouldn't talk about airport food
really even if you had a great bid on it
no because I've seen someone do a 20
minute bid on airport food and I was
like I don't want to do that that's
but they did it badly maybe you could do
it well do you have an airport you
probably do no
well maybe you should report food
I mean if I have something great to say
about it I'll definitely talk about it
it's not like something that I'm not
gonna ever talk about the best Popeyes I
ever had was in was it the Atlanta
airport
and then I went back to LA and they
don't know how to make Popeyes in it it
was bad yeah they don't have enough uh
Southern Culture there
yeah it was like all like black girls
back there just making yeah Popeyes with
their longer they're making it how they
wanted to eat it exactly that's how
everything should be made but
anyway
s
do you think food is an art like oh I
made a crunchy they're gonna love how
crunchy it is I think it's annoying how
I think food has been done everything's
done
there's these cooking shows what about
Fusion like Mexican and Taco uh Korean
tacos or whatever I just mean like
there's like certain cooking shows where
like they expect these people to like
make something that has never been seen
before and it's like that's almost
impossible to do
with food now I guess it's kind of
possible but it's like I hate oh I just
want to eat I don't want it to be art
yeah but some of the higher end [__] is
cool but
yeah I mean I think uh I used to be
really depends on I used to be a sous
chef so I'm like oh you're feeding
scarred from the restaurant industry
yeah it's just cooking is like a weird
mix of chemistry and
like a factory job
because you're just doing the same thing
over and over again yeah especially in
La it was like all about food like you
weren't even like I was a sous chef
there and like a couple fine dining
restaurants and you like weren't allowed
to care about anything else but food it
was yeah that had to be your life
dedicate yourself
to this minimum wage entry-level job
that wasn't my
yeah I got it to food because everyone
needs it yeah I mean I was salary I made
decent money but like
to not be able to talk about your other
interests at work with the people you
work with it was like weird yeah it's
like an office job what's the point of
working in a kitchen if you have to like
pretend to be dedicated to the company
especially like like Michelin level [__]
it's like that had to be your life yeah
well that's an industry that's full of
people that aren't really in it yeah
they're just trying to they're just sick
of those people make art out of food
yeah it must suck if that's like your
dream and your passion and then like
you're working with like a [__]
teenager or like some dude that's like
try not to die
yeah that was the worst part was like
being good at my job but having a 20
year old that's like new
tell me that their way is better
was it no it never was why were they
bossing because they just like bossing
people around well it got to a point
where like you couldn't you couldn't
like
be mean anymore yeah you couldn't like
say insistent he couldn't be like hey
don't [__] do that again that's wrong
like this is the fifth time you've done
that [__] stop like you had to like
yeah Gordon Ramsay I mean makes kitchens
sound a lot more yeah he was the last
one to be able to do that yeah don't
yell at me everyone has a mental
disorder now you're triggering my ADHD
yeah you can't yell at anybody anymore
they're all [__] back in my day we
used to be able to berate yeah line
Cooks I got berated that's how I got
better
it works but I got spanked alone naked
and the manager's Supply Closet tonti
that's [__] wrong throw it away and
make it again and you didn't [__] it up
again after that yeah I think it's good
to have
standards
but yeah I think kids nowadays
they just have too much confidence
they're like oh I know how to do this
yeah they're like oh let me play the
role of Cook
now as a cook I would be like this it's
like no start from zero you're nothing
build yourself up well also it's like
one of the only industries that you
don't have to have experience to like do
yeah they'll just like hire you if you
don't know what you're doing like you
can't do that you can't go be a mechanic
if you don't know how to work on a car
you had food you're eating yeah but
they're like oh you've never worked on
people you don't know how to dice an
onion come on we'll train you it's like
no this is a fine dining restaurant like
the roosters complaining that they're
too strict and they want you to dedicate
yourself now you're saying that they'll
hire anyone which one is it well at
first it was the first one but then I
got to a point where like they stopped
caring a little bit uh as the years went
on so then you got the worst of both you
got to experience the how stringent yeah
I got to see the shift of it should have
been the other way around it should have
been like oh yeah we'll accept anyone
and then later on it turns into
were a serious restaurant yeah it was
part of your experience it the opposite
it started serious and then they just
gave us like [__] after a while and
like here this person doesn't know
anything train them you [__] oh like
human beings yeah they're like [__]
yeah cook this yeah cook this Pig's
butthole yeah it's it's got so much hole
in it it's mostly whole
I love a good hole Yeah it's just empty
put some asparagus and bacon in there
so uh should we riff sure what do you
want to riff about let's riff about
the minimum wage
that should be higher
you good
no I hurt my hand
This thing always pops up I'm always
playing with it too
I think we should make I I want I need
fifty dollars an hour
for what when just didn't get enough to
survive oh really
yeah then you could work like 17 hours a
month
I barely work as it is that's good yeah
you're still making it work yeah I mean
I I work but we don't work too much
that's good yeah working is bad for you
yeah you're just giving your energy to
some Corporation that's going to use it
to make more napkins and my boss is cool
I buy my weed off of him
so he's chill okay that's fun I guess
um
that's cool so you uh you don't work
that much and you still how do you I
work five days a week but it's slow
right now so while we're there we're not
doing much you uh live with your
girlfriend yeah so that helps that's
half off rent true it's it's good work
living with someone yeah
is it good emotionally yeah we're doing
good that's good
my girlfriend and I
was our biggest fight is probably who's
gonna hang out with who
are you coming over am I coming over so
if we live together there goes 50 of our
arguments exactly then you'll have a
bunch of other [__] to argue about I
know then we can get to the root of it
what we really hate about each other
everything
and nothing
at the same time it's a beautiful love
no um yeah I mean it's just like if I
don't see her then what's the point of
having a girlfriend yeah but when I
moved here the plan was to get my own
place but I was gonna live with her for
a little bit until I found a place and
then that just didn't happen oh that's
perfect yeah it turned into just me
living there yeah like what's the point
of leaving
yeah do you like being with the person
and just getting really deep into one
person
yeah instead of like you know how yeah
on Open Mic days you go out and you meet
all these different people and you have
a little bit of yourself in every person
what do you mean like oh this is a
person I talk to when I'm happy this is
the person I talk to when I'm
talking [__] about other comedians I
mean I still have a couple people that I
talk to obviously I heard but like
because like
she gets annoyed with some of my [__] so
I have other people that have to
what does she get annoyed by your [__]
talking and you're a constant low energy
and
just the [__] talkiness the oh really
she doesn't engage in [__] talking she
doesn't let me complain about comedy why
because she's like you're lucky to be
doing it at all basically but she
doesn't look she doesn't uh that's good
you think it's a positive thing yeah she
won't feed into my negative because you
can get really lost in that yeah I'll be
taking negativity yeah and she'll like
bring me out of that and be like just
stop and then you actually meet those
people you're talking [__] about and
they're like oh hey it's good to see you
and all that just melts away it's like
oh I was just all in my head [__]
paranoid oh yeah sometimes me and they
don't like me to see them and they're
like what's up dude sometimes it's just
best not to think about things it
doesn't help thinking is very powerful
tool and if you use it on a place where
there's no result or it's not going to
result in anything then it just coils up
and you just waste time it's like
overclocking or overheating your
computer yeah that's my problem thinking
like I'll wake up in the middle of the
night to take a [__] and then I can't
fall back asleep because my [__]
brain's like racing thinking about
stupid like that [__] wasn't even big
enough to wake up for I'm not a real
person I'm not a real man
but uh yeah I really like this uh
podcast Studio
how long you've been doing this here
uh I mean I've had it for like a year or
two not parking pass I gave you was
expired it's August nice for July 31st I
gotta get a new one
am I gonna get towed no no it's just
they're probably gonna unless someone
calls it in
they call it in awesome never
these people are chill
people should park on the street anyways
super dangerous for everybody
I was on the street in Austin is that
because you got your van hit now you're
like bitter against street parking no I
just think it's crazy my friend has a
joke Eric Lundquist had a joke about how
like you can all right maybe it was
Andre Percheron from Seattle but he had
a joke where he's like you can just take
up the most valuable real estate in a
city like the square footage for like 25
cents an hour that shouldn't that
shouldn't be do you pay for the
Department that much I never pay for
parking here I've gotten a ticket once I
saw people ticketing and then I paid for
it right in front of tiniest bar
it's a pretty big bar
tiniest bar they got a big backyard yeah
but the actual bar is like yeah well
don't they have a bar outside
no it's just seeds uh well they should
have a bar outside but is that their
thing is their inability to serve
multiple customers yeah that's their
business model it's just one guy in the
back like in a no AC just overworked
over stressed and a little sweaty box
like just sitting there that's fun I
hope he enjoys it what's your favorite
thing about Austin
probably the lack of competition and uh
the lower standard of quality and comedy
now uh my favorite part is
the opportunity obviously my favorite
part is
you know like how it's a new scene it's
not got all that baggage from New York
and La they're not like all into
cheating to get ahead yeah they're
actually interested in comedy and I
think like Joe Rogan moving here and
Tony Hinchcliffe moving here I think
it's great because it takes like the
best part of La puts it here than
everyone else Falls in line to serve
comedy because those guys are comedy
they're not suits they're not interested
in making a commercial with you or
selling the rights to your image so that
they can make you know
napkins branded with your face on it
they're just interested in comedy so
from the top down it's all comedy so
then the only thing people here care
about is comedy they're not looking to
be actors or whatever yeah
that's what I like that I just want to
work in Mothership like yeah that's the
goal they want to sell their torso space
real estate so they kind of uh
please Brand me
I want to wear the hoodie outside of
work in 99 degree weather
yeah I think uh it's a great place
obviously
the Mothership
um
I guess I think uh
it's
it's like the perfect place to just
start anew instead of like with all that
baggage of LA and New York yeah no like
old guards all the old guards are like
off to the side they don't even care
they didn't really like comedy and the
people that really like comedy are part
of the new scene now yeah there's like
there's like old Austin Comics yeah I
don't even know what that means really
but does that mean like the people that
were here before the panda yeah the
scene that would have been here if Joe
Rogan didn't move here
but he scooped in and was like Hey it
would have been like any other City all
the Liberals quit because they didn't
really care they just wanted a place to
like be weak with other people at
and then the people that actually do
comedy and like comedy would have had
like a small scene starting over with
little bar shows here and there
would have been like Portland OR
whatever but now it's a supercharged
City there's like
industry and it was like business here
like we make money yeah
that's amazing I think people are like
traveling here for yeah that's crazy the
financial structure is so much better
here than anywhere else
they pick comedians nothing anywhere
else
yeah I had a friend that just moved here
from a comedy store and he was like I
have to come here just because
it's more now yeah it's like comedy
doesn't have to come from depressing
shitty places that's just where it comes
from because that's where all the power
congregates and pools but yeah you could
write comedy from anywhere Dave
Chappelle lives in Ohio
uh Gabriel Rutledge who's an amazing
comedian lives in Olympia for no [__]
race but he's amazing and he's writing
new material all the time he lives in
the middle of nowhere
I don't think location is as important
nowadays back in the day they could
control you they'd be like you want to
move to the big city now we can tell you
what to do and [__] now they don't have
that power
now it can just be about comedy and
let's see
who's really good at it and whether we
really like hearing each other talk or
not yeah that's what I like about here
it's kind of like are you funny or not
yeah
it's like weeding people it's not really
weeding them out they're still coming
back
but yeah comedians are hard to
discourage yeah you could tell them
don't ever come back and sign up again
and they still come back
yeah they're resilient they're a little
Barnacle because their personality is
their only savior if you tell them their
personality is bad they're like well
well then I I'm either gonna kill myself
or keep going so this is a brutal thing
about comedy it's like we don't like you
what you think is funny Who You Are
it's like you're putting your
personality on the line like physically
you're like oh this guy beat me in
tennis who cares I'm still a great
father yeah but then if you're a bad
comedian you're like your kids probably
hate you because your sense of humor
sucks
yeah we got a lot of those here
fathers bad comedians
I haven't been to open mics in a while
I should go check out the bad comedians
you don't need to where are you going
tonight what's the Design Spot
going to dinner tonight oh you're not
doing what if you weren't going to
dinner probably Secret show
a couple mics what mics
that's on Thursday
the Thursday ones are weird because
they're all outside and it's like I
[__] hate those why why are we doing
this still I don't know is this like a
vestigial memory well it's like they're
out they're like half indoor like the
place that they're at it's like a patio
but like it's covered but like it's not
covered so it's like it's half outside
like wait Buzz Mill
kind of like that or like the inside of
like narbar it's like there's
the back area that's like enclosed but
there's no roof so it's like you're
outside still I don't know I hate Lucky
Duck everyone loves Lucky Duck I've
never I've never been to that mic once
why I just haven't been free on
Wednesday nights really usually work I
mean I love Alden I think he runs a
great mic I think that's what you need I
mean I don't think like the fart noises
are the best but that's that's what
keeps the show going
um I just hate that the staff there hate
comedy they don't help out at all they
leave the TV on which I think Hurts The
Comedy a lot yeah there's a few places
like that where the mic it's like
secondary it's happening but they're
still doing their thing they're they're
stupid douchebags jock people that
constantly want to be distracted by
people running around and doing crazy
[__] on ESPN they don't know how to be
in the moment they don't know how to
actually listen to someone and they
don't like people they just want to
watch TV and do cocaine and hang out
with douchebags that you know will rile
them up do they love cocaine here
yeah they're like too casual about it I
mean it's the oil of drugs yeah it's a
short
is bad for the environment
it gets you a short little rush of high
I like the idea of cooking when it
destroys but people
doing it once I do it I'm like I
shouldn't have did that
but like I like I like the fact that you
can sniff something and feel different I
just wish it wasn't cocaine I wish there
was something healthier yeah I wish it
was heroin
this heroin not that bad because
everyone says heroin is so bad
I mean it's so good that it's bad I mean
yeah it's like it's you'll you'll
probably get hooked on it
that's good it would be my guess
if we get hooked on it maybe if you I I
think if you snorted it you would have a
chance to knock that hook but if you
shoot it you're gonna get hooked
well you wanna
end this right now sure okay we can go
back later if we want
thank you guys bye
I don't know what it actually ends
thank you